i ah
la cumbre de los países integrantes del
mercosur que tiene lugar en la ciudad de
asunción en paraguay vuelve a dejar en
la mira las discrepancias que hay al
interior de este bloque suramericano
sobre todo en torno a la relación con
china el proyecto de un tratado de libre
comercio entre uruguay y ese país
asiático es el motivo de discrepancia
entre los integrantes sobre todo con la
argentina las diferencias tienen origen
en la perspectiva que hay de uruguay y
de argentina montevideo dice que el
mercosur debe abrirse al mundo así lo
dijo su mandatario escuchemos en breve
día nuestros equipos estarán juntando
para empezar a negociar el tratado de
libre comercio
y por supuesto que ha avanzado esa etapa
lo primero que pretendemos hacer es
hablar con los socio del mercosur
es decir todos juntos e insisto tenemos
la tranquilidad de que esto ni vulneran
y erosiona ni quiebra
nuestra organización es la posición de
montevideo mientras que buenos aires-
afirma que la unión del bloque y apostar
por la producción de los cuatro países
debe ser la estrategia
existiera la posibilidad
y pensar en que china tuviera un acuerdo
con el mercosur porque no lo analizamos
juntos
porque no vemos la factibilidad junta no
nos ilusione la idea de buscar
soluciones individuales
en unas ilusiones la idea de que yo
puedo salir con un proyecto propio que
me alcance a mí
para china los mercados más atractivos
dentro del mercosur son sin duda brasil
e argentina que son los más grandes pero
uruguay que es un país muy estable
políticamente puede ser una perfecta
puerta de entrada a este bloque y su
atractivo es en este tipo de situación
en la que volvemos a poner en
perspectiva la posición que tiene china
en américa latina' la importancia de
nuestro mercado para beijing y como el
aliado histórico de la región que es
eeuu poco a poco está perdiendo terreno
ante una forma de diplomacia que es muy
efectiva pero que no está vendiendo un
modelo político de un estilo de vida o
de una democracia determinada como sí lo
hace washington simplemente es una
relación de ghana a ghana que en la
mayoría de los casos va a través de la
construcción y modernización de
infraestructura en este caso para
américa latina a cambio de que nuestra
región exporte recursos y materias
primas a china pero bajo la cuerda que
tanto está influyendo beijing en la
política latinoamericana que tan
importante es esa relación para a
nuestra región con el gigante asiático
que es ya uno de los mercados
comerciales más importantes del mundo y
que puede significar darle un poco la
espalda a washington lo vamos a analizar
en unos minutos por eso saludamos al
señor andrés rayo él es asistente de la
cátedra china contemporánea de la
secretaria general de flacso es también
coordinador sección uruguay de la
asociación latinoamericana de estudios
de asia y africa andrew se encuentra en
la ciudad de san josé en costa rica y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 con
nosotros se encuentra a angélica guerra
varón ella es doctora en ciencia
política con énfasis en relaciones
internacionales es co investigadora de
usted me corregirá angélica your york
como lo pronunció correctamente en esta
guión de la pontificia universidad
católica de perú les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas las
preguntas y comentarios que ustedes
quieran a través de las redes sociales
ustedes ya saben que estamos en twitter
en instagram también estamos en facebook
en donde no se encuentran como arroba
france24
es santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta se la recuerdo numeral el
debate efe 24 en youtube también nos
pueden encontrar para seguir nuestra
señal en streaming y también aprovecho
para saludar a las personas que nos
están escuchando a través de nuestro
podcast los invito para que escuchen
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
el debate de france 24 que ya está
disponible en las plataformas de apple
podcast spotify deezer y tuning
bueno pues comienzo entonces con nuestro
invitado de la ciudad de san josé en
costa rica andrés bienvenido al programa
como siempre un gusto para mí saludarlo
y la pregunta de inicio del programa me
gusta llamarlo el punto de partida para
conocer opiniones de los invitados
y creo que es una pregunta que tiene en
varias aristas para responder sería
comenzando por el lado de la
de esa pérdida de influencia que está
teniendo eeuu en la región de américa
latina frente a la influencia que está
ganando china y en el marco de esa
reunión del mercosur que tan importante
es esa relación que uruguay quiere
establecer con beijing una relación
directa a través de un tratado de libre
comercio pero que puede significar en
sacrificar en cierta forma la relación
estrecha que tiene con sus vecinos a
través del mercosur su opinión
bueno muchas gracias otra vez estar en
este programa un punto para mí lo
primero que nada creo que es un tema que
se puedes agregar en varias cuestiones y
que una cosa es su influencia y otra
cosa es el factor china y cómo puede
repercutir la política local y doméstica
y la política regional con cosas muy
diferentes y también la dimensión y por
supuesto también los niveles de la
discusión en el marco de las relaciones
de uruguay con china en concreto la
cuestión de uruguay ya hace bastantes
años tiene una relaciones estrechas muy
fuertes con chinos
primero desde un aspecto de socio
comercial este que ha sido muy
importante desde el principio del siglo
21 para el uruguay principalmente con la
venta de commodities como la carne la
soja la celulosa y posteriormente en
particular es hacer más o menos unos 5 ó
7 años hay una relación más estrecha a
nivel político pero no es realmente
discusiones de la política dura y pura
en cuanto a los ideologizadas
sino justamente sobre que trabajar o
formas de trabajar con planes hacia asia
en general tienen 5 años donde se
elaboran algunos objetivos en común y en
términos diplomáticos es más que nada
sencillamente las reuniones entre entre
las partes el diálogo generar instancias
canales de comunicación para desarrollar
diferentes aspectos como puede ser re
comerse como pues la cooperación como
puede ser inversiones o sea que el
uruguayo no ha pasado en gran medida
inversiones chinas en uruguay ahora en
cuanto a la incidencia política de china
de uruguay eso no se ha dado eso no pasa
en china no tiene alguna intención de
transformar la política nacional de
hecho de hecho desde los últimos 7 años
todos los partidos políticos han tenido
buenas relaciones con china tanto con el
estado chino tanto con el partido
comunista y como dijo el propio
presidente lacalle pou en los últimos
tardes cuatro gobiernos han intentado
tener una mejor relación comercial y
llevarlo a instancias de libre comercio
en particular el propio wen jiabao
cuando viajo desde china para mercosur
propuso algo similar
s no me dice ahora mismo y ahora si la
calle por lo cual es una sucesiva
eventos que se vuelven a repetir pero
todos caen en ese saco roto o en la casi
sin salida que es el marco azul y pasó
acá en el estudio de france24 angélica
guerra varón preguntándole por esa
pérdida de influencia que puede tener
eeuu en la región frente al avance que
tiene china y lo que significa uruguay
en esta en esta pieza en este
rompecabezas que ya lo vamos a seguir
conformando con andrés que es
precisamente uruguayo pero como ve usted
en esa relación de china a través de
uruguay para poder llegar al mercosur
bueno gracias por la invitación primero
que todo
creo que uruguay es una pieza demasiado
importante dentro del mercosur más allá
del tamaño que tiene este país en
términos geográficos pienso que puede
ser el inicio de una apuesta de parte de
la república popular china de qué forma
puede satisfacer la demanda creciente
que tiene de los productos primarios que
exporta uruguay o sea sin duda alguna si
nos vamos a mirar el mercado de los
cárnicos es impresionante el número de
toneladas de carne congelada por ejemplo
que exporta ese país a china y además
algo muy interesante en este aspecto y
tiene que ver con la participación del
sector privado principalmente los
frigoríficos que son uruguayos pero
también es importante decir que hay una
participación brasileña en esto donde en
la cadena de exportación de estos
productos que estoy mencionando
definitivamente uruguay es clave y buena
parte de los productos que exporta
uruguay debemos señalar esa carne
congelada que obviamente no podemos
reducir o no podemos utilizar este
ejemplo para generalizar creo que esta
participación de uruguay como un miembro
del mercosur que básicamente desafía el
status quo que hay dentro de este bloque
de los 90s es una muestra de cómo un
país está apostándole por fortalecer las
relaciones con un país como
este país asiático tremendamente
importante sin ojalá desestabilizar la
relación con eeuu de américa
yo pienso que son dos cuerdas y los
gobernantes deben saber manejarlas bien
porque porque una es la cuerda política
que muy bien andrés ha señalado en el
programa y por el otro lado está la
cuerda económica por supuesto que
uruguay el presidente actual se plantea
que pueda hacer y cómo puedo profundizar
y salir adelante de la mud de los
múltiples problemas que hay la inflación
a nivel global y los problemas con la
moneda que existen etcétera es la mejor
opción que ha encontrado su equipo de
gobierno es recurrir vuelvo y digo
desafiando el status quo que existe en
el mercosur con el acuerdo de asunción y
demás instrumentos que existen al
interior entonces es muy interesante
porque si bien es pequeño
geográficamente hablando en uruguay creo
que es una muestra de cómo
estas estos estados pueden replantearse
la forma como van a interactuar con
países con una influencia global e
innegable como china pero también a
nivel regional es un reto que es un
político y económico pero al mismo
tiempo en el nivel del relacionamiento
internacional de uruguay y con la región
la micro región y la región extendida
recoge dos puntos justamente las
exportaciones de lo que ha salvado
uruguay de este incremento del precio
del dólar que lo vemos en varios países
de américa latina uruguay lo ha podido
sortear mucho mejor debido a la gran
cantidad de exportaciones que están
teniendo en este momento el peso
uruguayo le ha ganado incluso terreno al
dólar estadounidense por lo menos en las
últimas semanas otro punto que yo creo
que vale la pena es destacar angélica es
como este país que usted dice es un país
pequeño 3.5 millones de habitantes pero
está negociando de tú a tú conversando
directamente con beijing para ver la
posibilidad de empezar a negociar un
tratado de libre comercio pero puede
también adquirir un liderazgo regional
como usted lo está diciendo puede de
pronto impulsar el mercosur a abrirse oa
modernizarse que ese es uno de los
puntos que vamos a analizar más adelante
quiero entonces que partamos el programa
en dos fases distintas esta primera fase
analicemos la situación del mercosur
justamente están en desarrollo esta
cumbre en la ciudad de asunción en
paraguay uruguay va a recibir la
presidencia temporal de este bloque ahí
está el tema de china sobre la mesa
uruguay y sigue insistiendo en este
tratado en tratar de negociar y buscarle
la forma que el mercosur se integre a
este a esta necesidad de tener una buena
relación con con china y la segunda
parte que lo veamos sobre china en la
región de cómo está en américa la
presencia de este país asiático y ahora
con todo el contexto de la guerra en
ucrania y cómo estamos en este momento
entonces para esta primera parte del
mercosur analicemos andrés discrepancias
pero argentinas de acuerdo a lo que
veíamos del presidente fernández ya un
poco cediendo viendo la importancia
sobre todo en este momento de coyuntura
económica muy complicado para argentina
hay una necesidad de negociar con china
y a través de uruguay puede ser la
puerta que le permita acceder a ese
mercado
el mercosur puede flexibilizarse
necesita una devolución es un bloque que
está tal vez con unas políticas muy de
los años 90 y la exigencia mundial ahora
es completamente distinta y uruguay
puede liderar ese cambio
bueno eso depende a estrategia nacional
de los estados soberanos dentro del
bloque y en este caso justamente lo que
nos convoca tiene que ver con esas
voluntades que coincidan y por supuesto
que se quede en fondo una cuestión de
inserción internacional y cómo se aborda
si claramente una cuestión de
flexibilización que los gobiernos
uruguayos han planteado y que también
otros gobiernos como el paraguayo nos
otros momentos no con china han
planteado es decir en ese aspecto está
claro que hay una voluntad que
trasciende los partidos políticos desde
algunos de los países al mercosur que sí
y una flexibilización ahora muy
distintos que era una modernización del
bloque es un concepto que se maneja que
tal vez un poco más confuso pero sí
ciertamente en el caso de uruguay o la
propuesta con china es una propuesta que
primero tiene un aspecto si bien es
comercial y cumplió absolutamente con
angélica hay un aspecto interesante a
nivel comercial que también le dio a lo
político que nos lleva al análisis
político es el uruguay desde hace más o
menos dos años está importando carne de
otros países de la región de forma
esporádica de forma más sostenida pero
claramente su capacidad productiva en
cuanto a los bienes de que comience con
china está llevando un nivel de tope no
quiere decir que esto no se puede
avanzar aún el tlc con china podría
incrementar aún más y generar incentivos
para que se produzca aún más pero
ciertamente la capacidad del país para
la exportación está siendo un límite y
eso nos preguntamos entonces por qué se
lleva con tanta necesidad las 13 con
chinas hacia el mercosur de pan de
uruguay a mi modo que tiene que ver con
un tema de manejo de agenda a nivel
discursivo que le habla tanto a nivel
doméstico como a nivel nacional e
internacional el gobierno tiene muy
claro la política exterior son activas
pero comercial e intenta hacer lo más
pragmático posible en un contexto
internacional donde es lo más
recomendable
pero que esto lo dejamos para después
pagar cosas y ciertamente esta propuesta
pone en la agenda y ese es el poder real
del uruguay hoy ahora el día de mañana
cuando se firme cuando se empieza a
negociar arranca se ha vuelta al reloj y
la arena ahí hasta el momento en que se
firme esa negociación que se termine ahí
empieza realmente la gran cuestión con
el mercosur uruguay hasta no firmar nada
no tiene ningún tipo de compromiso forma
ni discusión jurídica clara más allá de
las que vemos en las cumbres que son
políticas posicionamiento ag lo ha
logrado lo ha logrado pero también lo
había hecho uruguay en 2018 con una
reunión y reflotando una comisión mixta
que tenía con china y a mercosur desde
la 90 eso tuvo una reunión y no queda
más nada pero ahora en la propuesta
clara entonces en este marco argentina y
brasil hasta ahora no tienen por qué
mover ni hacer ninguna jugada
estratégica en plan que tiene que
esperar a ver qué pasa y si se firma ese
es el posible deseo no se firmó una vez
que se firme ahí si empieza una
excursión política necesaria y que la
agua de va a estar por supuesto mucho
más comprometido a cumplir lo pactado
con china
por este lado angélica su oposición y la
necesidad de renovar un poco este bloque
se ha quedado un poco arcaico en algunas
de las políticas le falta innovar
abrirse un poco más si yo coincido
contigo cuando lo plantea así es cuál
fue el mercosur que se gestó en los 90
claramente el contexto político
económico
de hecho la madurez del regionalismo en
los 90 era muy distinta de lo que se
estaba viendo en la actualidad creo que
uruguay está llamándonos a todos la
atención un poco me recuerda lo que
sucedía con perú y con colombia cuando
querían suscribir un acuerdo con la
unión europea y también demandaban la
flexibilización ya vemos el resultado
actualmente uruguay en esta
sosteniéndose de la política aperturista
que de hecho se consolidó desde los 90s
en ese país y a través del presidente
actual estamos escuchando y escuchando
un relato donde se quiere retomar esta
importancia que le quiere dar
precisamente el al derecho internacional
y al derecho internacional económico
porque es importante este relato
presidencial porque a la final es
decirle a los uruguayos obviamente a los
sectores interesados ganadores y
perdedores miren lo que yo estoy
planteando y tengamos en cuenta que esto
se plantea desde el año 2020 cuando el
presidente estaba adelantando su
programa y su campaña
en la actualidad está este llamado de
uruguay es por ver qué va a hacer con
sus relaciones comerciales y por
diversificar las el considera y por las
palabras propias del presidente que el
mercosur se ha quedado un poco
dentro de las ideologías y ha dejado un
poco de lado la política de estado con
respecto al comercio
obviamente que estos temas están muy
asociados a la política exterior pero el
mismo presidente lo señaló desde un
inicio entonces me parece que este
anuncio que hizo no se debe tomar
primero como algo sorpresivo y segundo
desde el discurso del presidente hay una
consistencia de una coherencia por eso
demanda que haya un nivel de
flexibilización de parte del mercosur
que por supuesto el presidente brasil
bolsonaro le ha le ha encontrado cierto
eco a esto y por otro lado una
resistencia clara
parte de paraguay de argentina como tú
lo señala hasta el inicio del programa
entonces vaya que viene un 1 y unos
discursos y unas estrategias que desde
lo político y lo jurídico van a empezar
a gestarse es sin duda ya lo han estado
trabajando estoy segura las carteras de
comercio y de relaciones exteriores de
uruguay son en su puesto es que es muy
paradójico ver como en el nacimiento del
mercosur
siempre se veía a uruguay a paraguay
como unos países que se van a beneficiar
de dos motores económicos como alan
argentina y sobre todo brasil y que eran
los que iban a jalar ese bloque y van a
abrir a estos países al mundo porque
eran las grandes economías del cono sur
y uruguay y paraguay siempre se les vio
como que eran los países que se iban a
beneficiar y poco iban a aportar ahora
de una uruguay liderando promoviendo
jalonando hacia una modernización y a
los otros países grandes simplemente
viendo como esto si es lo que queremos
hacer en nuestro país y se quedan en esa
parte política y en esa en esa parte
ideológica
andrés en la ciudad de san josé le
pregunto
en esta cumbre que tiene lugar en
asunción uruguay va a recibir la
presidencia temporal aquí la estrategia
puede jugarle a favor a montevideo para
para mover las cartas a su favor para
tratar de convencer un poco más sobre
este tema qué beneficio puede tener
uruguay tener la presidencia pro-témpore
y que tiene bajo la manga la república
oriental para esta presidencia
ok primero que nada la capacidad de
agenda justamente lo que hablábamos es
la capacidad de poner en la agenda
algunos temas y convocarlos a los
estados miembros que en este caso
recordemos además de los cuatro
mencionados hasta ahora venezuela está
suspendido que no tiene hasta esa
participación entonces tiene la
oportunidad e convocar a los
participantes de los miembros de la del
bloque a tratar temas que consideran
pertinente entonces sí por supuesto es
algo positivo en tener la posibilidad
colocar los temas en agenda siempre
tiene algún algún beneficio que puede
lograr resultados óptimos o su óptimo en
cuanto a quién carta tiene bajo la manga
sana gran pregunta para hacerles muy
sincero yo creo que lo que mencionaba
angélica creo que esto tiene que ver con
lo discursivo y un relato a construir en
el cual después se puede sostener
justamente sus próximas alocuciones y
sus próximos encuentros con otros
presidentes y esto es una influencia en
la jurisprudencia era de lo jurídico
sino que además genera costumbre perdón
de la costumbre de expresar lo expresado
expresado los técnicos decir ok miremos
para atrás yo vengo reclamando esto hace
mucho tiempo eso es importante esa
después el uruguay y de tomar ésta
lo que sí es cierto es que el
posicionamiento que está tomando un
lugar el día de hoy esto podría ser una
crítica es que es es esto o no es nada o
sea la opción que está proponiendo
uruguay es abrámonos con china no está
viendo abrirse con otro con otro país
que los socios del mercosur no compiten
entre sí para exportar porque recordemos
esto también son competitivos entre
ellos con china es decir todos se venden
los mismos productos y por no es un
socio menor está en 32 25 20 está en
casi todos los casos en el top 5 autos 3
entonces estamos hablando desde un
acuerdo con un país que puede modificar
la matriz productiva de algunos otros
países en concreto de uruguay por lo
cual la estrategia es sentarse sobre la
idea de que uruguay va a reclamarlo y
varias de las últimas consecuencias
partiendo de la base que es el jurídico
uruguay no está violando nada sino que
la cláusula 32 del mercosur del 2001
pero antes la causa es lo que establece
es que haya consenso entre las partes en
caso de que uno quiera ser un acuerdo
bilateral claro no obstante lo que dice
uruguay es que eso no se internaliza eso
no entro a la propia
normativa uruguaya ni mucho menos de
tres países la región y que otros países
también han aplicado normas como brasil
para bajar las teles pero con que sería
de lancer externos brasilero nada más
común donde éste tampoco se respeta el
consenso negro aquí entramos otra vez a
esta calle sin salida que se ha
mencionado al principio la supongamos
que jurídicamente no pasa nada pero
cuando políticamente una decisión es
contraria a la interés nacional de uno
estos países miembros se van a quedar de
brazos cruzados no van a hacer algún
tipo de retaliación no van a aplicar
algún tipo de política en detrimento del
uruguay la respuesta es muy probable sí
bueno ya vamos llegando a la mitad del
programa voy a avanzar entonces
terminamos aquí esta parte del mercosur
y la relación con uruguay además es un
tema en desarrollo esta cumbre está
teniendo lugar en la capital paraguaya y
a lo mejor en las próximas horas o días
hay algún pronunciamiento por parte del
bloque frente a este tema por lo que
dejamos el análisis ahí en punta con lo
que pueda suceder en asunción y lo que
pueda pasar una vez uruguay asuma la
presidencia pasó entonces aprovechando
esta controversia que hay con china y la
relación con uruguay y las discrepancias
con argentina y en otros países del
mercosur para evaluar y mirar cómo está
la posición de china en la región como
está en américa latina' vale la pena
hacerlo en este momento por el contexto
en el que estamos eeuu tiene muchos
problemas en su política interna su
prioridad es el tema migratorio con
méxico y al resto de la región tal vez
lo deja como un poco quieto no hay mucha
interacción entre los países de la
región con washington y la guerra en
ucrania pues también es un tema en donde
china indirectamente está involucrado y
hago la pregunta entonces angélica
evaluemos la posición de china en este
momento que está aprovechando esta
coyuntura internacional esta política
eeuu que viene desde el gobierno trump
un poco distanciado con la región para
ganar influencia como esta políticamente
para china en nuestra región pienso que
china está sabiendo jugar muy bien su
papel sino una vez resplandeció a través
del ingreso a la o mc en el año 2001 no
ha hecho sino crecer y por supuesto
demandar económicamente muchos más
insumos una vez pasamos esta época del
boom de los productos primarios
demandados por china y bueno luego se
dio la recesión en el año 2008 nos
estamos dando cuenta como china de una
manera bastante
inteligente se ha encargado de
fortalecer los lazos con aquellos países
que obviamente satisfagan sus
necesidades en este sentido pienso que
también ha habido una inteligente
estrategia de identificar e identificar
cuáles son los socios con los cuales en
américa latina china debería profundizar
su relación en ese sentido la forma más
hábil que ha podido establecer una vez
se lanzó la idea del del balón road
initiative fue incluir a los países
latinoamericanos que quisieran suscribir
un memorando de entendimiento con china
y eso fue genial porque porque es una
forma de a través de mecanismos de
cooperación llegar a resultados que
satisfagan lo que ellos quieren entonces
desde una perspectiva más global
podríamos decir que es una forma de
extender el poder o sea un poder suave
que le han permitido
paulatinamente tener una presencia no
sólo económica sino política claramente
no nos países más que nosotros por
ejemplo venezuela y al mismo tiempo
lograr su plan interno quincenal bien
entonces a mí me parece que esta acción
ha sido una estrategia inteligente
cuando uno mira las políticas exteriores
de los países de latinoamérica no
necesariamente encuentra que haya
claridad de cómo lidiar con china no sea
sólo fijémonos en el tamaño y sólo
fijémonos en la capacidad de influencia
que tiene por ejemplo a través de
tanques de pensamiento
pensaría que no pero realmente es algo
difícil de cuantificar pero muy valioso
en este en esta lógica pienso que la
presencia de china es cada vez mayor no
solamente a través de las dinámicas de
importación y exportación sino a través
de algo súper importante y en la
búsqueda de proyectos de infraestructura
que financiar y es por ejemplo la
búsqueda de acuerdos con países que
produzcan productos como el litio que es
bastante conocido que chile-argentina
son unos de ellos y se está dando un
triángulo una triada bastante compleja e
interesante ponerse a jugar exacto
interesante económicamente
peligroso desde la perspectiva
medioambiental
entonces fíjate como china por otros
mecanismos yo diría que bastante
diferentes de lo que ha hecho washington
tradicionalmente con américa latina y el
caribe lo que ha hecho china es ingresar
a través de los memorandos de
entendimiento y mucho a través de sus
empresas obviamente propiedad estatal
pero con algunos interlocutores privados
y siempre vivir mayor cosas a cambio a
nivel de democracia o político sino
simplemente a nivel comercial contraria
a la estrategia eeuu que pedía
establecer unos valores democráticos a
la luz de washington que es lo que
siempre la han criticado desde desde
otras partes del planeta andrés veíamos
en la cumbre de las américas en la
ciudad de los ángeles a eeuu muy afanado
por intentar de establecer un plan
millonario precisamente para mejorar
infraestructura en américa latina para
tratar de acercarse en la región llega a
eeuu ya muy tarde a la presencia china
donde ya están a todo nivel con
infraestructura comprando materias
primas comprando productos alimenticios
invirtiendo acercándose y sobre todo con
el establecimiento de cada vez más
líneas directas cada vez tenemos más
vuelos de conexión con china desde la
región de américa latina que eso pues
acerca de agilizar el comercio aún más
si tarde y al mismo tiempo cuando
intenta volver a escena lo hace de forma
errónea y con métodos arrolló con
métodos clásicos que es justamente
muchísimos gobiernos de américa latina
no nos gusta entonces es decir hay un
doble error en cuanto a china sin lugar
a duda de las intenciones tienen que ver
con su visión mucho más pragmática de
hecho por el hecho de estudiar china una
repregunta constantemente las cuestiones
que tienen que ver sobre las formas de
gobierno de las democracias
autoritarismos jerarquías etcétera y en
realidad al día de hoy a mí no me consta
y no escuchado sobre presiones al
respecto a las formas de gobierno de
imposición de valores de hecho todo lo
contrario aquí la política exterior
chinas de los 50 para aquí se basa en
los mismos cinco principios que por
supuesto responden a intereses
nacionales eso no cabe ninguna duda
todos los estados y todos los gobiernos
también tienen sus propios intereses e
intentan de algunas formas cumplirlos
los de ciertamente ha pasado y me gustan
mucho lo que dijo justamente angélica y
que trabajamos al respecto cuando
creamos estas cosas tienen que ver con
la capacidad que ha tenido china su
política exterior es exclusivamente para
no exclusivamente pero en concreto con
américa latina' de generar canales de
diálogo de multinivel quiere decir a
nivel sistémico como pueden ser en
relaciones unidas como puede ser dentro
del brics justamente con el caso de
brasil la posibilidad argentina no es
menor para el caso anterior de uruguay
también considera la posibilidad de
argentina de brix ayuda también a otros
factores externos a nivel de china celac
a nivel de las relaciones entre entre
países con asociaciones estratégicas e
incluso con los hermanamientos entre
localidades en todas esas funciones si
china ha propuesto canales de diálogo y
eso es clave para la cohesión génica
ellos tienen sus intereses pero pueden
promueven más de una relación de win-win
decir ganar-ganar y consultan cuáles son
los aspectos que los países piensan que
deben trabajar en común bajo una órbita
operativa y coordinada y esto y como
dice angélica y es una crítica que a
veces cansa mencionarla porque es un
poco recreativo pero claramente no se
observa una estrategia en particular de
la región con la salvedad es justamente
que hablamos en él
y justamente le va a preguntar eso y le
pido que sea muy puntual porque ya me
quedan pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa y es la estrategia o hacer la
ronda a la inversa ya lo de la palabra
angélica la estrategia china no está
pensando en una estrategia presente esto
es siempre están pensando a futuro de
mediano y largo plazo pero en américa la
tiene el futuro y mediano y largo plazo
prácticamente no existe es una
estrategia casi siempre cortoplacista la
mayoría de los países cuál puede ser
entonces la estrategia de latinoamérica
para mejorar la relación con china y
cuál es la estrategia de china en
américa latina al mediano y largo plazo
bien a pesar de que uno quiere sonar
ingenuo pero clásico de la estrategia
china en américa latina es muy evidente
en todos estos niveles que mencionados
es decir uno encuentra cuando estas
cosas que en todos los niveles se
repiten digamos los mismos conceptos las
mismas ideas es decir por lo menos
oficialmente lo que chinas quiere está
plasmado y la solución a las estrategias
de la región nuevamente está bien claro
que tiene que encontrar algún organismo
alguna institución o incluso algún
liderazgo claro para poder canalizar una
estrategia en común cuál sería
estrategia en común pero que la mayoría
país américa latina tiene el mismo
problema y poder exportar productos
primarios los problemas que tiene que
dar un empleo genuino tienen que generar
inversiones que generen empleo y que al
mismo tiempo eduquen generen no sólo en
el house sino que generen inversiones a
futuro y como vos dijiste muy bien eso
no es el pan de cada día sino es la
característica de américa latina'
planear y pensar en un futuro a largo
plazo en angélica estamos en un momento
de la coyuntura internacional que la
guerra de ucrania nos ha mostrado un
escenario que pensábamos que no íbamos a
ver
en nuestro presente un nuevo conflicto
un frente de guerra abierto después de
haber de haber visto lo de siria y una
de las razones que da rusia para
justificar esta invasión es tratar de
forzar un quiebre y forzar un nuevo
orden mundial a través de este esta
invasión aquí américa latina que juego
puede llegar a hacer en donde en este
juego chiíta ha estado muy calmada muy
tranquila muy callado frente a la
invasión y a la posición que tiene con
rusia pero américa la tiene que puede
llegar a ser en ese posible orden
mundial que se pueda armar es una
pregunta muy interesante porque
cualquier persona podría decir que
américa latina no tienen ningún rol en
este en este conflicto
bueno podría pensarse en principio que
así es sin embargo nosotros no debemos
perder en perder de vista perdona
toda la tecnología que existe a nivel
militar por lo tanto si tú miras cuáles
son los aliados de eeuu vis-à-vis cuáles
son los países que son o que tienen
ciertas líneas de convergencia con china
te vas a dar cuenta que latinoamérica
así puede jugar un rol importante y lo
digo porque si bien china ha tratado de
mantener una posición neutral
con respecto al conflicto que hay y que
generó rusia al mismo tiempo debemos
tener en cuenta esto y es quiénes son
los países que se encargan de vender el
material armamentístico para los
diferentes países en latinoamérica eso
por un lado por otro lado trayendo el
tema de la tecnología y lo que puede
suceder en un conflicto que se viniera o
sea mejor que se extendiera al conflicto
armado a sitios algo a cualquier país de
américa latina podríamos un poco jugar y
pensar en lo que pasó en los 60s como
por hardware nosotros podríamos pensar
en lo que sucedió perdón con la crisis
de los misiles si podríamos darnos
cuenta que definitivamente la posición
geoestratégica que tiene venezuela por
supuesto que es importante de un 'vis a
vis' con colombia eso explica por qué
razones la postura de venezuela con
respecto a todo el conflicto ha sido una
y por qué
colombia con el presidente de duke
decidió que tenía que mejor apoyar a
eeuu o sea un poco hacer el ejercicio de
pensar qué sucedería si los intereses de
un país como eeuu se vieran en juego por
el desarrollo y la importancia de rusia
y los efectos que está trayendo esta
nueva idea de generar un orden mundial
entonces ese es un escenario que podría
parecer poco probable pero realmente se
dio si nosotros nos vamos otra vez a
hacer el ejercicio que les mencionaba en
los sesentas
por otro lado pienso que
hay que tener mucho cuidado y en este
sentido sí me parece muy interesante la
postura que asumió mercosur de cómo va a
participar o relacionarse con lo que
está sucediendo en ucrania el mejor
ejemplo es no le vamos a permitir al
presidente de ucrania que haga una
llevar una participación en él en la en
la cumbre por ejemplo es decir
simplemente hablar como lo ha hecho en
otros ejercicios con el congreso de eeuu
y lo mismo en el reino unido pienso que
están básicamente cuidándose de no
ingresar en un terreno que quizás no
sería muy conveniente políticamente
hablando y si tienes en cuenta los
intereses económicos y todo lo que tiene
que ver con el armamento y a los
movimientos financieros que sean a
partir de ello tiene sentido claro tener
una posición más firme me queda ya o con
segundos para hacer entonces la
conclusión rápidamente andrés por favor
muy puntual porque me queda menos de un
minuto conclusión china en américa
latina' que va a suceder para el futuro
predecible la utilización de los mismos
canales establecidos hasta ahora a nivel
multinivel justamente y a nivel
comercial un comercio un comercio
sostenido y procurando en hace posible
genera valorizado visto y por este lado
angélica conclusión un pienso que china
está ejerciendo su estrategia de una
manera muy inteligente por un lado a
nivel multilateral con la presencia o la
afiliación de diferentes estados a sus
iniciativas sea a través de los bancos
de desarrollo sea a través de su
iniciativa que ya mencioné el programa y
por otro lado mercado en mercosur atento
pienso que va a seguir el debate y
quizás se van a profundizar los roces
pero es bastante probable que lleguen a
la idea de una posible flexibilización
aunque sin usar los términos del
presidente uruguayo pues angélica y
andrés les agradezco por este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nuestra
programación
[Música]